you went to Egypt right dude did you eat
carbs there I did dude the food sucks in
Egypt man yeah hey but I sold no [ __ ]
dude yo but yes [ __ ] like I put no [ __ ]
no no you've been there for six thousand
years you can figure out [ __ ] food
nothing but named something they've
invented there's nothing the pyramids
well that's how I know that he's an
alien it's not aliens but it's not them
it's probably white dudes it might have
been white guys across the British some
of ogres from one day it was a gift
real talk no there's no way like
everything about that [ __ ] the pyramids
it just blew my [ __ ] mind that's the
most impressive thing I've ever seen in
my life
like I literally you're the only person
every person I let see the parents like
dude they're kind of small was it [ __ ]
there's McDonald's like out out front
wait people have [ __ ] on the pyramids
almost every Rhino it's guys they're
pairs like that whoa whoa what do you
all want state pyramids name somebody
Cowen for sure no way yeah I was doing
some operation other half yeah we take
it out yeah I've never heard great
things about the pyramids I've always
heard they're overrated huh
but you loved them done they're the most
underrated thing I've ever seen in my
entire life they are the most marette it
questions your idea of reality it makes
you question reality you're watching it
and in live you we were questioning how
could this happen
like I don't even think about human
progress the same way after looking at
the parallel wow this is how I think the
pyramids happened I think there were
some humans they built the pyramids they
developed these cool you know -
technology that allowed them to do it
those humans died out and because we
didn't live in this like global society
where everybody knows what's going on
when you died so did all your technology
yeah you can't tweet it out right so
then another group of humans thousands
of years later the one that we call the
Egyptians now they pull up they see some
dope [ __ ] and they're like yo last hours
cuz you would claim whatever is your
100% and then every group that walked up
on it just claimed it the Greeks the
Romans the Jews anybody who pulled up on
it was like yeah we made that that was
us that's our people but there's no way
in [ __ ] hell any humans they're like
you know subscribe you the alien but you
know I think we just say alien when we
don't know how things happen in our
reality and that's why I'm talking about
question reality like these [ __ ]
things the bricks themselves are so
massive there
no way in hell you could move those
bricks and you know that they didn't get
those bricks from that place there are
like 17 kilometers away to cross the
river with them yeah like there's all
this insane [ __ ] suspect this white
suspect you know what makes something a
civilization a group of people of
civilization writing right that is what
made the Egyptians of civilization
writing the hieroglyphics yeah so how do
you write about
everything but how to build that that's
why they say aliens no even if aliens
did it they would write the aliens did
it and I know someone's gonna point at a
hieroglyph where they're like an alien
looking thing no you go in detail about
how those [ __ ] aliens it you wanna do
a shot at theater would you want to
detail a [ __ ] corn but you're not go
to detail on how you build this there's
nothing here the idea that they say the
Jews built it absolutely [ __ ]
because if you look at the Old Testament
they go into detail about how to build a
temple everything the the cloth has to
hang two centimeters below that there's
such specific minor details how to build
a temperature not how to do know writing
whatsoever nobody else replicates it and
you know what you see this [ __ ] in
Mexico other parts of the world gets
stacked up son that's what it is but at
one point time was perfectly flat oh
they chipped away it at over years using
it to make weapons etc this was
perfectly straight there's a mock-up of
what they're supposed to look like back
in the day so these days we have a one
or a dollar bills too well because
that's strange
now the Masons the people who basically
created America yeah they were inspired
by the Egyptians and they think they're
like philosophy is that every once in a
while yeah this is what they thought
this is what they look like back in the
day perfectly flat white if you're
talking about the Luxor and that's what
it looked like how you think they got
that idea when it's supposed to be white
there was blind stone son it was perfect
white limestone that's what it's made
out of 6,000 years you get a little rust
should order no dude I'm telling you it
is you cannot you cannot imagine it now
it I'll look at the pictures looks
pretty sweet wait here's the other where
Isis is in North Africa like a
[ __ ] Isis is done bro now we're
dealing with [ __ ] coronavirus from
these two right like what the that's the
big issue right now why do you have to
put everything
in the soup that's you can't make soup
without bats guys that was a little bat
let's be honest when you see because I
know neither of your Chinese when you
see the Chinese do Chinese [ __ ] right
like put a bat in soup do you are you
like oh we're now we got a deal with
this
Abbas Asians absolutely before
especially but yeah is that [ __ ]
annoying or Asian but that's annoying
yeah it's not you guys know right I know
you're stressful it's like it's on you
check every time a terrorist thing
happens all the Muslims go [ __ ] an a now
we got to deal with this at the TSA go
China's like Asian Isis in a way in a
way there's a bat hanging in the soup
like it's a [ __ ] Jacuzzi jacuzzi bath
he's just a suit like this yeah it's
great and you don't think it's gonna
cause some Corona but look at it Isaiah
was he legs and he looks a date yeah
that's right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]